Look, I didn't want to be a half blood. Being
a half blood is dangerous.
It's scary.
Most of the time it gets you killed in
painful, nasty ways.
If you think you might be one of us, my
advice is turn away while you still can.
Because once you know what you are. You'll
sense it too. They'll come for you.
Don't say I didn't warn you.
My name is Percy Jackson. I'm 12 years old.
Am I a troubled kid?
Yeah, you could say that. Bad grades,
bullies, all the normal stuff.
And then there's some other stuff. Some stuff
that's maybe not so normal.
That's me back in second grade. Why was I up
there?
I saw something.
At least I could have sworn I saw something.
When you say you saw something like that, you
wind up in this guy's office. Good news.
He's saying there's nothing to worry about. It's
all in my imagination. But if it happens
again, make sure to tell someone. It happened
again.
These impossible things that felt like they
walked right out of the stories my mom always
told me.
So real one minute.
Next...
What a loser.
Hey, fellas, want to come hear about the
imaginary stuff I see? It's not a thing you
want to be saying. To anyone, so I didn't.
Then something changed.
I met Grover.
We had a lot in common.
And not just because we're both at the bottom
of the food chain. And you know what? It felt
good to talk about these things with Grover.
You can almost believe they were imaginary.
Weird, but harmless.
Until the day that changed too.
Until the day one of them decided to come for me.